قالت الخارجات الاسطونيه ان استونيا تعمل
على ايجاد تشريع لاستخدام اصول روسيه
مجمده خاضعه للعقوبات لتعويض اضرار الحرب
باوكرانيا من جهه قال مكتب الرئيس
الاوكراني فلودي انه يجب تمويل اعاده
الاعمار على حساب روسيا وتمن تحرك في
الكونجرس لنقل اصول الروسيه الى اوكرانيا
وقد تقدم عدد من المشرعين في مجلس النواب
الامريكي من الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي
بمشروع قانون جديد يهدف لتوفير مساعدات
اضافيه لاوكرانيا من خلال استخدام الاصول
المصادره للبنك المركزي الروسي والتي تزيد
على 300 مليار دولار حول العالم ويمنح
المشروع او مشروع القانون الرئيس الامريكي
سلطه مصادره الاصول السياديه الروسيه التي
تم تجميدها في الولايات المتحده وتحويلها
للمساعده في جهود اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا
ويحضر الافراج عن الاموال للكيانات
الروسيه الخاضعه للعقوبات حتى تنسحب روسيا
من اوكرانيا وتوافق على تقديم تعويض عن
الضرر الناجم عن حربها
ينضم الينا من واشنطن مراسل جزيره محمد
العلمي محمد تفاصيل مشروع القانون هذا
المقترح من الحزبين الديمقراطي والجمهوري
وما هي الاليه لكي يتحول الى قانون فعلي
وليس مجرد مشروع
واذا لو بدات من الجزء الثاني من السؤال
الى ان يتحول الى قانون على البيت الابيض
رئيس بيض التحديدا ان يقبل به واذا قبل
بالفكره
سيشجع
زملائه في الحزب الديمقراطي بتصويت عليه
في هذه الحاله يمكن ان يصبح قانونا حتى
الان لا نعرف موقف البيت الابيض في الحاله
الاخرى اذا كان المشرعون الامريكيون من
الحزبين
يتمتعون بحماس كبير لتمرير هذا القانون
فعل الغرفتين النواب والشيوخ ان يصدقوا
على مشروع القانون باغلبيه الثلثين في كل
غرفه بعد ذلك يصبح قانونا على الرغم من
رغبه البيت الابيض بوجود القانون من عدمها
بالنسبه لمقتضيات القانون فيدا هناك مشروع
القانون عفوا هناك مجموعه من الاليات
يوفرها هذا المشروع
يمنح البيت ابيض الصلاحيات من
لنقل الارصده المجمده ومصادرتها وتحويلها
الى اوكرانيا والعمل على مستوى الدولي من
اجل حمل جميع الحلفاء على فعل الشيء نفسه
اولا لمعاقبه موسكو حسب المشرعين الذين
يتبنون مشروع القانون لان روسيا في نظرهم
على الاقل هي المعتنيه هي الظالمه هي التي
ترتكب جرائم حرب حسب اعتقادهم وبالتالي
يتعين ان تعاقب وايضا لمساعده اوكرانيا
وتخفيف العاب على دافع الضرائب الامريكيين
والغربيين الذين تحملوا الان مسؤوليه
التسليح اوكرانيا وعلى موسكو اذا ان تتحمل
مسؤوليه اعاده بناء اوكرانيا ومن غير
المستبعد ان يتم طرح مشروع هذا القانون في
مؤتمر في لندن يعقد في وقت لاحق هذا الشهر
حول جهود اعمار اوكرانيا لكن في هناك بعض
المشاكل